une houle comme en haute mer des rafales
frôlant les 300 km/heure au coeur de
l'ouragan
levac cern cette maison de toutes parts
le propriétaire film la montée des eaux
impuissants la porte du garage a déjà
été emportés maintenant l'on rentre il y
a beaucoup d'eau environ deux mètres à
50 selon les autorités des bahamas
l'ouragan dorian est le plus puissant
qui ait jamais touché le pays par tous
ces bourrasques assourdissantes et ses
pluies torrentielles qui déclenché la
panique
s'il vous plaît priez pour nous face aux
inondations ses habitants se sont
réfugiés à l'étagé ils découvrent leur
couloir dévasté envahi de morceaux de
toiture leur appartement
méconnaissable ton appartement mon dieu
la fenêtre
les touristes sont confinés à
l'intérieur des hôtels comme ceux france
et joint par téléphone plus personne
parce que l'ouragan
il est encore ici depuis près de 24
heures dorian balaie tout l'archipel des
bahamas
il se déplace lentement en direction de
la floride et a particulièrement touché
ces îles à baco et grand bahama
treize mille bâtiments au moins ont été
endommagés ou détruits
devant l'ampleur des dégâts le premier
ministre a bien du mal à cacher son
émotion
c'est probablement le jour le plus
triste de ma vie est le pire jour pour
s'adresser à la population
pour l'heure aucune information
officielle n'a été publiée sur
d'éventuelles victimes
[Musique]